all right we are now
live for what is going to be reading
number three
from my book which is now 10 years old
a reason fulfilled by revelation the
1930s christian philosophy
debates in france so i'm glad people are
enjoying these and i'm going to keep on
doing these i'm
guessing until we reach the end of the
book
it's going to be a little while before
we finish up
with the introductory materials but i'm
sure that you'll
bear with me on that and that will
eventually get to the translations which
are the real
meat of the book so we're gonna do
another reading
followed by q a and discussion
um we're gonna go from page
21 to
let's see here what is it page
39 so got a lot of reading ahead almost
20 pages we'll see if we can get through
this
and this section is called the debate's
french
context so first part catholic thought
and
radicalism 1931-36 debates were
primarily french ones and accordingly
these broad outlines sketched above
require
much more specific content in terms of
the concrete situation of french
philosophical and theological thought
to paint in very broad strokes one of
the deepest fault lines running through
french philosophy and that most
important to the start of the debates
lay between catholic and rationalist
thought
understanding that term in the broader
sense it took on
during the debates the french
philosophical establishment or more
properly speaking the philosophical
establishment of the secular state
schools of the third republic
was deeply marked by
here we go irrationalism hostile
indifferent or contemptuously dismissive
towards religion
developed by and indebted to a long line
of many figures and traditions of modern
philosophy particularly
descartes voltaire the encyclopedias
rousseau kant
setting these figures intellectual and
cultural heroes to the secular
philosophical establishment
side by side under rationalism's rubric
indicates of course that this
term is not meant solely in the sense
whereby phyllis philosophy textbooks
oppose continental
rationalism to british empiricism but in
a broader sense
involving appreciation of the powers of
philosophical reflection
critique and method to supply an access
to truth incorporating but going beyond
mere sensibility
or experience rationalism also
signaled confidence both in the ability
of human reason to plumb the depths
of the fundamental questions not only of
philosophy but of life
and in reason's capacity to guide itself
to produce and apply
processes of inquiry and self-critique
used in this journey towards its goals
in this broad sense rationalism included
varieties of philosophical idealism
materialism and positivism
where the real distinction lay was in
the view
at times insisted upon at times merely a
dominant assumption that reason could
only mean
unaided natural and human reason for any
aid
any admixture with the irrational the
presumed
supernatural vitiated reason leading it
into dogmatism's cul-de-sacs and dead
ends
integral to modern rationalist positions
was this binary distinction
between what they counted as the
rational and what they
rejected as the irrational
closely allied to it was a
distinction between the philosophical
and the unphilosophical
for in their view christians could be
philosophers and philosophers could be
christians but any specifically
or intrinsically christian philosophy
would be something merely sectarian
lacking in the autonomy and universality
characteristic of
genuine philosophy one catholic observer
of the debates ramon fernandez pointed
out the overly restrictive way
rationalists construed
reason catholic rationalism he said is
waging a lively offensive at the moment
when skeptical or nash
irrational there we go skeptical or
naturalist rationalism is transforming
itself in its depths
so that what the former retains of
reason and values corresponds to what
the latter reduces to the rank of purely
verbal dialectic it must be mentioned
that
specific events and intellectual
movements in french history and culture
could be
and were read by secular rationalists as
confirmation about their views about
reason and religion particularly
about roman catholicism some of these
dated back to
pre-revolutionary times but more
significant were those taking place in
the decades
prior to the debate the facts yeah
the draft affair split the french nation
and friend catholics as well
but in general the church was perceived
as on the side
of the right in favor of dreyfuss's
condemnation
that controversy would pave the way for
the rise of charlema's
reactionary and proto-fascist movement
action francaise
which despite its founders atheism for
some time held the allegiance readership
and membership
of many french catholic philosophers and
theologians including jacques mariten
and reginald
lagrange and even members of the
hierarchy
a major catalyst in these alliances with
axiom frances with
the modernism controversy involving many
official condemnations
and placement of works on the index but
also an excessive zeal
and haste to run to accusations of
modernism at times off base
by anti-modernists against perceived
philosophical and theological opponents
next section the catholic intellectual
renaissance
in france although
france and the third republic was a
secular state at times
militantly so french intellectual life
included
many individual catholics and catholic
institutions
and because of the supernational
condition of the
catholic church these were naturally
affected to varying degrees by major
developments in the larger church that
bore on issues germane to christian
philosophy a revival of the previously
quiescent vitality of roman catholic
thought in the late 1800s
took place with particularly strong
resonances in france
due in part to the momentous events the
nation passed through
in part to intellectual ferment and
conflicts
the times leading up to the debates were
marked by major new initiatives
and involvements in philosophy by french
catholic thinkers
some of them at odds with each other but
all of them
contributing to it generating a
situation in modernity
in which debates about christian
philosophy could take place
and draw a great interest and in which
catholic intellectuals
after the first conflicts with secular
rationalists
could be found espousing robust
developed coherent but radically
differing philosophical positions both
for and against the possibility or
existence of christian philosophy
and about christian philosophy's nature
arguably the most important of the
developments
in the universal church was the eternity
potras
the encyclical quickly subtitled on the
restoration of christian philosophy
advocating a return to and restoration
of saint thomas
aquinas's philosophy viewing it as the
prime example of christian philosophy in
the sense of philosophy furnishing
the most comprehensive fruitful and
orthodox understanding
of the fundamental matters that the
christian faith and the catholic church
had to
grapple with three points about this
document with implications for the
christian
philosophy debate must be noted very
briefly here
first while thomas is held up as an
exemplar
leo the 13th discusses many other
christian philosophers in the document
and tomism is not
identified as the sole form christian
philosophy could take second
the encyclical explicitly contrasts
thomas's thought with deleterious errors
tendencies and conditions of modern
thought but it urges
that thomas and his interpreters be
reinterpreted
rather than simply superimposed upon
the new conditions of modernity
third the encyclical discusses both
speculative
and practical concerns the latter
practical in two way attorney patrice
highlights the implications
philosophical perspectives bear for the
church and for
quote domestic and civil society and it
also spells out a general institutional
program for the restoration of
philosophy
in the catholic church specifically
advocating thomas's doctrine be taught
in universities
the encyclical's earlier noted lasting
effects had particularly significant
consequences
for french catholic thought the impetus
that gave
neo-scholasticism was felt in several
generations of scholarship among which
are to be numbered many of the scholars
who took part in the 1930s debates
as well as the professors and
researchers who formed them
it had lasting institutional
consequences absent which
there probably could have been no later
debates
chairs into mystic philosophy and
theology
were established in the various
institute catholic a
and seminaries as the dominican andre
donaion
recently observed until the foundation
of the review thomas by
mondone coconier and guy road in france
in 1893
quote no catholic journal had previously
deered
or wanted to present itself as tomist
until then lacking a forum of their own
french thomas writers had published
their research in the jesuit journal
etude
in la sions catholique
in time they would have the review de
philosophie from 1900
the archive the philosophy in 1923 and
the review destions philosophy
legit from 1907. the latter associated
with
le salshoir another important center for
domestic studies
numbering among its members certified
and marie dominique from 1894
the review neo-scholastic philosophy
which is currently the review
philosophical event
would also provide a key forum connected
with the institute's superior
philosophy in luvan devoted to to mystic
studies
directed first by cardinal mercier
followed by marista wolff
and in the debates years they don't know
well
although not in france producing faculty
and students who would later take part
in the debates
most notably fernan von steinbergen and
joseph marshall later in 1923 the
society tom east founded by mandone
would add to these the bulletin thomist
by
founding and directing jill sohn himself
would contribute by adding the archive
the eastward doctrine doctrinal literary
demoionage in 1926
and etude philosophy medieval in 1930
this revival of tomism in france and in
nearby francophone countries
attributable both to attorney potress
and to the scholars who responded to
and implemented it brought about several
other
key developments first as mentioned
previously renewed studies of thomas
aquinas
in particular studies of historical
orientation had the effect of reviving
uh study of other medieval and even
patristic philosophers and theologians a
project that would be
both furthered and formative of one of
the debate's main participants
etienne gilson second french tomism was
never all one solid and uniform block
and controversies even divisions arose
not only over
proper interpretation of the authentic
thought of thomas
but also over how reinterpretation
should be oriented in relation to modern
thought
most significantly a mutual influence
developed between
maurice blondell the philosopher of
action originally highly critical
of contemporary talmism and a number of
tomists
whose approach to aquinas either drew on
or found consonances in blondel's
thought some of these for example
antoine and certian joseph mareshall amy
farrett
uh henri de lubeck took part in the
debates while others for example pierre
guide broglie may be said to have laid
their groundwork by contributing to
stress lines separating the different
catholic interlocutors the third effect
of the thomas revival was that tomism
and in particular its neo-scholastic
interpreters became an enduring
intellectual force to be taken seriously
if not necessarily well understood as an
interlocutor and opponent on the french
philosophical
scene
other magisterial documents and two of
leo the 13th writings in particularly
in particular importantly inform the
context of french catholic intellectual
life
his 1891 encyclical ray rum novarum
inspired the social catholic movement in
france a movement that gave rise not
only to the later banned movement
but also to the still presently act of
cement social
and in 1899 his letter to the french
bishops and clerics
deputy le jour regarded attentive
perusal
of the itany potras again criticized
tendencies of modern philosophy
and urged following the program outlined
in the encyclical
french catholic intellectual life was
also greatly affected by pius x 1907
pascendi dominicki gregas occasioned by
the earlier mentioned modernism
controversy which bore considerably on
philosophical matters
not so much producing as bringing into
full light deep divisions
in french intellectual life the
renaissance of catholic thought was by
no means confined to thomas or
neo-scholastics
on the philosophical scene two figures
stand out as particularly
important the first andrea bergson not a
catholic himself
nevertheless exercised an important
influence on catholic thinkers
by his ground clearing critical attacks
on the rationalist intellectualism
prevalent in french philosophy and his
emphasis on experience and dynamism
some such as maritime so and credit
bergson's thought is having drawn them
out of sterile
philosophical paths readying them to
move past him to a christian perspective
that he himself did not supply
they as well as many other catholic
philosophers and historians of
philosophy for example ari
would devote attentive study to beric
sohn's philosophy and beric stone would
even draw a lifelong modernist
catholic disciples such as edouard lahoy
blondell
was the other key figure whose
philosophy influenced not only certain
thomists
drawing the fire of others but also
other philosophical voices in the
debates
among them gabriel marcel etienne born
andrei brahman and louis paul kochet
next section the main participants in
the debates
context conflicts and christian
philosophy
in the nearly unanimous view of
contemporary french commentators on the
debates the most important interlocutors
essentially defining the central lines
of the debate
were either song jacques mariten and
maurice blondell
taking positions for christian
philosophy and
emile braille leon brunchfig and
fernando von steinbergen taking
positions against
it several other interlocutors are
arguably of major significance as well
arguing for christian philosophy gabriel
marcel
antenan certian amy fourette antonin
mott andre guiller
and michelle suryo arguing against it
the neo-scholastics pierre mandonet
and leon noel a penumbra of only
tangentially or occasionally involved or
less well-known and discussed
commentators
surrounded these major commentators
major interlocutors
many of the participants in the debates
had developed close
numerous and long-standing contacts and
in several cases
had previously engaged in conflicts with
each other
the francophone intellectual and
religious milieu encompassed networks of
overlapping
interacting though not always mutually
understanding or appreciative
philosophical and theological
institutions and circles
the three societies mentioned earlier
the society process
philosophy and the society included and
through their organs and formed
many of the writers who would
participate in or comment on the debates
the society frances de philosophy was
also closely connected by its membership
with the state
educational establishment and like it
included many catholic philosophers
with publishing houses and with one
journal in particular
that was to provide a significant
battleground early on
in the debates that reviewed
metaphysique a morale
the society told itself a reflection of
the international communications
connecting thomas scholars
counted primarily french or francophone
philosophers and theologians among its
ranks
connecting them intimately with leuven
school and with le salshoir
but also extended to german austrian and
italian contexts
the smaller society detude philosophy
with its organ
etude philosophique brought into regular
communication and dialogue
a surprisingly large number of important
philosophical minds membership
readership
and interests of all three societies
overlapped
quite arguably only the sort of complex
the french milieu provided which
possessed this
wealth of institutions societies
relationships
and forms for debate or publication and
in which no single one predominated
could provide ground fertile and yet
fractured enough
to nourish and sustain five
years of intense and continued studies
and debates between so many
first-rate philosophers and theologians
interestingly if the three most
important catholic interlocutors or
rather four if marcel
is included were laity rather than
clergy and were philosophers who
underwent their formation in secular
french schools rather than in
catholic institutes universities or
cemeteries
maritin and marcel were converts the
latter quite recently in 1929.
joseon and blondel were raised catholic
but deliberately decided to study in the
french
state institutions rather than catholic
institutions
joseon rather sanguinely blondel after a
period of discernment
and retreat during which he decided
against seminarian priesthood for
himself and in favor of marriage
teaching and writing
which he regarded as his lay apostolate
of course of course these thinkers all
moved and had numerous contacts in both
secular
and catholic philosophical and
theological circles catholic clergy
figured among the more
important interlocutors and debates and
many did become deeply and extensively
involved in discussion and take sides on
christian philosophy
but it is worthy of remark that at its
most
absolutely central points the debates
about christian philosophy
took place largely between lay catholic
philosophers
with their feet solidly planted in both
catholic and sexual
secular intellectual circles
many issues of the 1930s debate were not
radically new to the major catholic
interlocutors
blondel had been addressing the
relationship between philosophy
christianity and catholicism in major
works
in correspondence and occasional pieces
for nearly four decades
jill saw had published several major
studies of particular medieval christian
philosophers
as well as work demonstrating descartes
previously unacknowledged dependence on
scholasticism and had been appointed as
professor
of the history of medieval philosophy in
the sorbonne in 1921.
mara tenant established himself as an
erudite and original interpreter of
thomas aquinas
also engaged with and knowledgeable
about
contemporary non-thomas currents of
philosophy
six particularly significant
developments in french
intellectual history three very
proximate in time to the debate
set the determinate context for these
particular interlocutors
sustain sustained interest in and
disagreement about the issues involved
in christian philosophy
for the main lines of conflict and for
the important certain themes assumed in
the course of the debate
first decades earlier in the century
the long brewing modernist controversy
took place
a controversy blondel found himself
entangled in
largely because of his accion 1893 his
letter
on apologetics and history and dogma but
also through his associations
particularly his friendship with the
augustinian and
vehemently anti-tomas lucian la
bertoniere
his involvements with the french
catholic social movement
a social catholic movement the cement
social
in the letter on apologetics blondel
articulated an
explicit position on the issue of
christian philosophy
one that he would later revise to some
extent but later stick
largely stick by this earlier position
criticized scholastic philosophy
which at that time blondel only knew
through manualist proponents
rather than through direct reading of
thomas aquinas or through his later
interaction with more able
interpreters as unsuitable for reaching
modern minds and for meeting
philosophy's own demands
he produced several other important
works traces of which can be discerned
decades later in his contribution to the
christian philosophy debate
history and dogma in 1904 and the testis
articles demand
defending the cement social against
their anti-modernist
uh catholic opponents charges of
sociological
modernism none of this endeared blondel
to many tomists
nor did the influence of his philosophy
and other thomas mentioned earlier
the key magisterial documents set out in
1907 during the modernism controversy
pascendi and lamentability
not only defined modernism as a heresy
and delineated its key features and
intellectual structure
but also contain detailed institutional
and disciplinary instructions and these
strictured allows
allowed rationalists to feel confirmed
in their views on catholicism's
authoritarianism
and incompatibility with modern
autonomous thought
during the controversy some
anti-modernists in their use of the term
and concept
went way beyond the encyclical texts or
the specific decisions and judgments of
the vatican's
charging and denouncing many as
modernists
those involved with charlema's
proto-fascist organization accion
francaise took some part in this
and that movement's involvement in
french politics culture and religion
also played a considerable part in
mutually estranging some catholic
philosophers from each other
blondel and mara 10 in particular
blondel was one of accion francaise's
strongest philosophical critics while
maritime
remained a member of that organization
until its condemnation by pius the
11th in 1926 after which to his credit
he gradually but rad
radically revised his views of accion
frances and charlemagne
a second connection between blondel and
mariten also separated them
arguably leading both of them and many
of those following or
influenced by these two great french
thinkers into never to be overcome
and largely unnecessary mutual
misunderstandings the catalyst was
blondel's contribution to the 1923
volume
the possessed intelligence through the
1920s blondel and maritime entered into
a polite but contentious correspondence
and engaged in scholarly and public
controversy
focused on the issues raised by the
piece and the nature of intellect
the types of knowledge and their
correspondence to concrete reality
considerable and in the eyes of many
unbridgeable differences
already existed between the
epistemological and metaphysical
perspectives
of blondel's philosophy of action and
contemporary
interpretations of saint thomas
blondel's piece
effectively a misstep and blind alley on
his part
and mauritan's critiques unnecessarily
widened perceptions of incompatibility
between blondeling and thomas
philosophies an important fruit of which
in the debates would be joson's
erroneous conflation of bergson's
and blondel's position in his society
francis de philosophy presentation
meanwhile in the decades prior to the
debate
a third development involved other
significant differences that had arisen
among neo-scholastics and tomis in their
interpretations of the nature of
medieval thought
specifically on the relations and
distinction between philosophy
and theology as noted earlier the new
impetus and
institutional support given to study of
saint thomas aquinas after attorney
potress
translated into renewed study of other
medieval christian philosophers and
theologians
the richness of medieval thought is
particularly evident in the variety and
fruitfulness of the approaches adopted
towards its texts thinkers and systems
the case of atm joseon the levant
historians illustrates the differences
arising and solidifying among tomist and
neo-scholastic philosophers theologians
and historians
joson distinguished several differing
christian philosophies
discernible among medieval thinkers
whereas mondonet
and later von steinberg among others
maintained that what jilson claimed for
philosophy
was actually theology and that it was
imperative to maintain a strict
distinction
even separation between them leading you
also later to charge
quote the same christian thinkers who
just desired to establish in our own day
of philosophy
independent of theology were simply
projecting into the past their own
doctrinal ideal
anxious not to lose contact with their
own tradition these teachers adapted it
to their own needs they constructed a
medieval philosophy as completely
independent of all theology
as their own claim to be these
long-standing differences of
interpretation would set the stage for
jill sones and mariten's critiques of
neo-scholastic
positions and for the 1933 tom east
meeting in particular
the society thomas or the sorry the
society frances de philosophy
itself provides a fourth important
portion of context
two meetings in the years just prior to
the debates were particularly
important not only because of the topics
but because of the participants debating
the topics in march 1928
brunchfig made a presentation to the
society
on the eponymous topic the debate about
atheism
his respondent was his former student
joseon and their debate was largely a
draw
but it set the stage for the later march
1931 session
particularly for the jill some brunswig
exchange
blondel contributed a letter to the
debate and marcel
lahoy and lenoir participated in
discussion with brunchfig
the 1930 session on the problem of god
and philosophy eduardo
presenting involved fewer participants
in the debates but signaled the
continued interest in matters of
philosophy and christianity
one individual who might be aptly called
them moran marcen
of the 1930s xavier leon founder of both
the society
frances de philosophie and of the
reviewed metaphysique di morale
assumed a pivotal role by bringing
together many of the debate's early and
most important participants
suggesting the original theme of the
1931 session and publishing some of the
key
early documents in the journal fifth
the 1500 year anniversary of saint
augustine's death in 1930
saw a number of publications dealing
with augustine's works and thought
preceded by jill solst
augustine jill sol mariten and blondel
each contributed essays to
a monument to saint augustine the former
two also participated in the augustinian
thomas week in rome
and published articles in review de
philosophie while blondel contributed an
essay to the
caier the nouvelle journey a piece in
which blondel explicitly contrasted
his interpretation of augustine with
jill sones
and published another article in the
review de mere physique in morale
in several of the 1930s articles you'll
see more
martin and blondel explicitly discuss
christian philosophy characterizing the
term in ways prefiguring both these
philosopher's positions
more fully developed in the course of
the debates and
the conflicts to come between them
sick the augustinian the augustine
articles
were part of a larger and slowly
developing wave
of articles and books employing the term
examining examples and occasionally
discussing the concept of christian
philosophy
several early pieces and discussions
closely antidating the debate indicate
the interest
that the topic was starting to receive
in 1927 in the review neo scholastic de
philosophy
maurice de wolfe asked was there a
scholastic
philosophy in the middle ages receiving
replies from among others
joseph martial and blaise romeier
1928 saw emme forets
in the inaugural issue of v until xuel a
popular forum
assuming central importance in the
debates in 1929
leon noel published his retrospective
the
and in the same year a curious document
can philosophy progress within the
framework of the christian faith
purportedly authored by quote an eminent
french catholic publicist who preferred
to remain anonymous for the present
end quote was published in the journal
of religion
were published in 1930 in 1931 the
prolific
region olivet published his his book
essay
philosophy
in which the third study responding to
brahir
helenism a castianism is dedicated to
quote the problem of christian
philosophy
at the same time the rationalist authors
were presenting and publishing the works
that would define their positions in the
debate
and throw down the gauntlet to the
proponents of christian philosophy
emil brayer had been progressively
bringing out his history of philosophy a
key
section of which appeared as an extract
in 1927
key because he argued that the patristic
age produced
no christian philosophy a claim he would
generalize
the same year brunswick published his le
pograd de la concience
philosophy articulating once again the
idealist and secularist position he'd
long advocated in which religion
stripped of its irrational elements and
forms could be translated
transformed into genuine spirituality
that is
philosophy in 1928 at a set of
conferences in belgium
brahir presented his thesis now
developed at length
that quote one can no more speak of a
christian philosophy
than of a christian mathematics or a
christian physics
the term an interest in the issue of
christian philosophy
thus gained currency from both its
proponents
and its opponents in the decade prior to
the debates
next section uh bergstone and
phenomenology two other philosophical
movements deserve brief mention in any
adequate outline of the debates french
intellectual context
one centered on a particular thinker
ahri bergson
the other being the broader movement of
phenomenology
in spite of publishing his two sources
of morality and religion in
1932 bergstone ended up with practically
no involvement in the debate this
lack of engagement is particularly
striking not least because many of the
debates participants and commentators
had written or would soon write on
bergstone's philosophy
he was regarded as a major figure in
contemporary french philosophy credited
by many including
jacques and rice mara 10 for having
revitalized metaphysics in france
and the roy one of his most
distinguished followers made a minor
contribution at the start of the debate
jill solo in the course of the debate
would criticize blondel and bergstone
along the same lines as philosophers of
the concrete
bergson's only tagental role does make
sense however following
romeier's analysis of the two analysis
of the two sources of morality and
religion as a work possessing a
quote christian soul but an incompletely
christian content although equally
opposed to the rationalists
bergson's philosophy had no effect of
contributions to make
to a debate about christian philosophy
not already made more strongly by
catholic participants if the
relationship of bergsonian philosophy to
christian philosophy is non-engagement
phenomenologies relationship is
considerably more complex even down to
present times
when for example jean-luc mario argues
for the impossibility of a contemporary
christian philosophy drawing precisely
on uh
phenomenology and adrian pepperzak
constructs a christian philosophy
drawing on phenomenology
contributions from phenomenological
perspectives
during the 1930s debates where few came
late and exercised
relatively little direct influence but
three particular points
are worth brief note first there was no
agreement
among phenomenologists about the
possibility or the nature of christian
philosophy
several of the phenomenological
movements most important figures
in particular edmund husserell martin
heidegger and mark schaeler
either made no philosophical space for a
christian philosophy or explicitly
rejected its
very notion at the same time other
phenomenologists
in particular edith stein and dietrich
von hildenbrand regarded their own work
as christian philosophy and grappled
with issues raised by the debates
accordingly land noel's contribution
translated here
impresses husserlian phenomenology for
the neo-scholastic goal of demonstrating
christian philosophy's impossibility
while gabrielle marcel's position de
mistiere ontology quesa
concrete translated elsewhere harnesses
phenomenology precisely
for the purposes of further developing
christian philosophy
a project and contribution whose values
and prospects
henri de lubac at the end of the debates
recognized explicitly linking the
potentials
of marcel's and schaeler's thought
invoking these two thinkers raises the
second point which is that the projects
and perspectives
assembled under phenomenology's rubric
were neither new
nor entire alien to the french
philosophical scene
in fact as christian eve dupont
persuasively argues
both bergson's and blondel's
philosophical works and influence paved
the way
for german phenomenology's entrance the
similarities between the blundellian
method of imminence and his later method
of implication
and phenomenology are long well attested
but were already noted in 1930 by joseph
mareshall
who drew explicit comparisons between
blondels and husserl's
philosophies shaler himself apparently
knew blondel's work early on
and marcel discussing the philosophy of
the concrete integral to his conception
of
christian philosophy clearly
acknowledges his own debts to blondel
who for his part though carrying out
philosophical work clearly akin to
phenomenology against little interest in
engaging the movement the third point of
note is that
some thomists became interested in the
prospects of the phenomenological
movement
von steinbergen signals the inroads
phenomenology was making
into catholic circles twice in the
article translated here
phenomenology was the very topic of the
inaugural society thomas day of studies
in 1932
when the benedictine daniel foiling and
the redemptorist kramer made
presentations the latter invoking the
question of christian philosophy
and edith stein numbered among the
participants
in the course of the second day of
studies in 1933
employing phenomenology foiling argued a
point similar to noel's
that a christian philosophy cannot be
philosophy in a rigorous sense
jolivet set his finger on the rising
interest in phenomenology
seeing in quote mr husserl's
phenomenology
whose influence is preponderance in
germany a powerful metaphysical
renaissance that though
quite a few aspects through quite a few
aspects comes to corroborate
certain central views of tomism
doubtless it is not a matter of properly
or specifically christian doctrines
but the directions or the tendencies are
such that they can
only encounter thomas philosopher's
sympathies
and that is the end of that section the
next part is a
much shorter part which we'll read in
the next reading i see there's quite a
few
questions and comments so let me jump to
those
let me scroll up here um
godward podcast asks about something
that is
mentioned a little bit in the christian
philosophy debates but
is uh way way earlier than it that's
justin martyr's dialogue with with
trifold
so justin martyr gets mentioned as an
example of christian philosophy
he obviously does not take part in the
debates which is what what we're talking
about here
because uh he was over a melania late
or early rather to them avarose do you
support radical fundamentalism and
philosophy i have no idea what radical
fundamentalism
means that could mean a million
different things so that's an
unanswerable
question um let's see
scroll down some more uh marc s about
simone vane
she didn't participate in the debates
she's she's uh
sort of coming to prominence uh in the
30s
but she's not she's not part of this
this um
discussion at all edith stein of course
uh is so she she's uh somebody to take a
look at
all right um
yeah so mark mark says that that uh
simone vay was critical of mara tan
she was critical of marutin as were many
other people but being critical of mara
tan
could be done from many different
perspectives um
they weren't necessarily connected with
these debates that are that are going on
um i mean you could have been critical
of maritime for be for lining up with
the
uh proto-fascist accion process right
um all right let's see here
made a clay says you missed 30 minutes
yeah these will usually start at the top
of the hour
you see them publicized on the youtube
channel
ahead of time and in my social media so
you can always you can always check the
reason i owe calendar as well
all right um colomous has a good
substantive question here do you think
that the rationalists would have
rejected the possibility of religious
philosophy generally
or only christian philosophy in this
specific context so
um it's it's actually rejecting religion
in general
and you know the rationalists are pretty
eurocentric
if we're talking about breyer and
brunchfig you know the west is where
the cool stuff is happening as a matter
of fact i i would suspect although i
haven't looked at bray here on this
that he would consider basically only
western philosophy
to be genuine philosophy
and he he thinks that that a lot of you
know things in the past are not really
philosophical when you read his
contribution to to the debates
um he kind of dismisses hellenistic
philosophy most of medieval philosophy
right um so i i think that they would
in interestingly they probably would
have considered christianity to be like
the most developed religion
and then you know if christianity can't
contribute to philosophy then
you're not going to find any of these
other uh religions contributing to
philosophy either
mark says did these debates make any
reference to earlier such debates such
as those that occurred between early
christians and pagan thinkers
the debates themselves you know the
debates are
are basically the people involved in the
debate so so really we can say
did any of the people involved in these
debates make reference to
those and the answer is yes jill so in
his uh
spirit of medieval philosophy that's one
one place to look at because he's
looking at a sort of historical view
there
and he does talk about early christian
philosophers not just justin martyr but
loctancias
and clement of alexandria um
[Music]
and then you know blondel also talks
about some of them
and there's other other people more
often minor figures
talking about that in the debates andrey
guillermo the historian of philosophy
would be
important there
be charlemagne have any place in this no
thank god because because mara really
was a proto-fascist
and uh sort of like a conte you know of
that time steve bannon
um who who didn't have an awful lot in
terms
of like understanding of christianity
can to contribute
um but actually frances was a real stain
on french catholicism for
about you know 20 20 odd years
um so no he he didn't have any
part in it but some some of the people
who were influenced by him you know he
mentioned
jacques martin who later repudiated him
and uh i mean garagu lagrange had a
brief entry into the debate
as usual you know kind of tendentious
and getting some of the stuff wrong
um b also asked does abelard versus de
claravo i have historical echo here
not at all i would say um
that's that's a whole different you know
sort of sort of issue about
like you know what counts as
spirituality and what should the mind be
directed to
so i don't they're not really mentioned
much in the debates i mean joso himself
writes on bernard de clervol you know so
he would be worth
checking out um
let's see skiff asks is it possible that
as human brains become what they are
today with ability to survive increasing
the mind began
to use more of its capacity to think of
much of what became a spouse in theism i
mean anything's possible but those sort
of like
wild you know big picture
evolutionary psychology or biology
things
there's really no evidence for them it's
just kind of like telling a cool story
and
i i don't find the story those sort of
stories very interesting or adequate to
understanding human
human beings and historical um you know
uh developments of religion or anything
like that so
made of clay with c.s lewis in these
debates c.s lewis was not he's
c.s lewis is not a francophone to begin
with
and he doesn't i don't know of any uh
interest on his part in these uh debates
um but you know there's there's many
important figures who did not take place
take part in these
debates um you know
christian philosophy debates in france
is is uh
pretty much where the debates are are
happening or at least in francophone
journals some of them based
in belgium
[Music]
all right so b has a thing by cameron
quantum mind am i right i have no idea
what that's supposed to be
referencing or connected to so does
anybody have any questions
specifically about the book its topics
what we what i you know ran through in
terms of the french
context um there's there's quite a bit
of content that i threw at you about
that
i'll be doing another reading
this coming week not sure exactly when
maybe
maybe on a saturday maybe on a sunday
and that'll be a shorter reading
all right cola moose did so-called
french materialists have much of an
influence on the debates depends on what
materialists you're you're talking about
i mean
i would say that ultimately um
you know i i think that you can say that
um
brunshfig although he's he's got this
reference to
you know esprit which can be translated
as mind
um and he's sometimes called an idealist
i think he really
is the sort of you know contemporary one
who's it is still materialism but
there's nobody who's like
self-identifying specifically as a
materialist
in the french scene getting involved in
these debates to talk on behalf of that
i mean i i i have a hard time thinking
of people who
identified first as materialists and
then as
something else usually it's the
something else you know so like for
example sart
is a materialist right but um
sart is an existentialist first before
that that's where his his main
allegiance lies
and and other than uh you know brunchfig
and brahir as i mentioned the the people
who were
secularists or rationalists didn't
really have much involvement in these
debates
timothy what important connections do
you see for the religious theological
turn in contemporary phenomenology in
these debates
so i actually mentioned that a little
bit earlier in the book
and i'm going to see if i can track down
the thing
and my my um basically what i did is
call [ __ ]
and say there isn't any recent turn
to you know theology in phenomenology
it's not a recent turn it's been going
on for a long time
i don't see it in the book but i mean
think about paul recore right so paul
recur
antodates um uh michelle henry and
you know uh jean-luc mario and all those
types right so it's been continually
going on
and um it also you know you can call
[ __ ] by saying listen
phenomenologists were interested in this
stuff
way way back in these debates
i'd also point out there's there's
another great phenomenologist
a french guy john erin who uh
was working in the mid 20th century and
was doing you know
phenomenology of religion of course
earlier phenomenologist
edith stein mark schaeler so this this
recent
theological turn
it's more of a sociological phenomenon
than like a big
you know uh change in things it's just
that that some of the
people whose books were being published
were now looking
in phenomenology we're now looking at
religion but there's a long long
you know backstory to that
all right b um how did the dreyfus
affair break down along sectarian lines
within french christianity
um so french christianity is largely
catholicism
and you do have some reformed
but there's not a lot of other kinds of
protestants in france
and what you can say is that um
you know the the catholics who are more
on the right wing the traditionalists
the anti-modernists um
they were the ones who were anti-dreyfus
and they were like hang the guy you know
terrible terrible
guy you know let's let's punish him as
much as possible
those who are motivated um by more of a
you know uh social justice ray ram
navaram
orientation um living up to the the
social teachings of the church um and
you know teachings about truth and stuff
like that
were uh generally on the side you know
to to equip dreyfus
um accion francaise got itself involved
and that's really what gave it its
impetus you know these
deep divisions within within life
um marx says it seems to me an
undercurrent to the issue of christian
philosophy is the question of what
philosophy is
am i right in saying the debate baiters
weren't entirely clear on this point no
you wouldn't you wouldn't be right about
that
um they you know when you read the texts
and and what they have to say they are
crystal clear on that point
um they don't always agree on what
philosophy is but
you don't have any such consensus
agreement among philosophers
at any point in history even going back
to you know the era of socrates and
plato right there's multiple
ways of understanding what we should
call by this term philosophy
but there is genuine inquiry into what
is the nature of philosophy
these people that's part of why this is
such an important debate
because they are raising issues not just
about well what about this this you know
side religion christianity and you know
then how
could it impact philosophy they're
asking these are
you know genuine deep metaphysic
metaphilosophical
issues that that they are raising and
exploring
and it's probably never been delved into
at least the connection between
christianity and philosophy which is
complex
it's not a simple thing it's never been
delved into quite so deeply
as during the time of these these
debates
nathan do you think stoic
self-sufficiency and virtue and
character is compatible with the
christian notion of needing christ's
holy spirit to
achieve this well who's christian notion
i mean it's not like christians are in
total
agreement on that right so and stoic
self-sufficiency and virtue and
character
it's not as if there's a single stoic
view on that there's kind of a range of
stoic views
is there a compatibility between them i
would guess that the people who called
themselves neo-stoics
in the renaissance an early modern era
would say yes because
they were both christian and stoics
so so clearly some were and actually
there's a lot of of uh
stoic thought that gets incorporated
into
christianity at least in the early you
know the patristic era
and during the medieval era because you
know who are they reading
uh seneca survived cicero survived you
know epictetus
survives in kind of a bulgarized way
um so you know we whenever we're posed
with like one of these sort of questions
we always got to clarify clarify clarify
whose model whose ideas are we using
here
um and so some people say yes some
people say
some people say no um
all right cola moose says i should
clarify meant how much did french
enlightenment philosophers such as
dietero
dietero is is you know long dead by the
time that these debates are taking place
and i mean he doesn't really have any
impact on the debates
um
um norwood you know like helvetius or
people along those lines because even
like secular philosophy had moved on
quite a bit from from there
so they're they're not they're not
really having any sort of
role the older uh enlightenment
um evolution and
uh materialists no they're they're not
they're not really involved in this
um i mean
maybe it's like a boogeyman in the
background for a few of the
the uh catholic interlocutors
but not any of the important catholic
intellectuals they have bigger fish to
fry you can say
right all right any other uh
questions about the debates the
people involved the french milieu
the book itself any of that sort of
stuff
going back to the the stoic thing though
i will mention this
um the only person
as far as i remember who really talks
about the stoics is
brahir the rationalist and and he's
dismissing
blondel's philosophy saying that it's
basically like you know hellenistic
philosophy
it's only a philosophy oriented towards
practical life and
stuff like that uh mark did your work on
this book change your understanding of
christian philosophy in any way or were
you set going in i'm
i'm almost never set going in on any
research project
um and yeah i mean it
i started out doing some
translation of blondel and von
steinbergen that somebody had sent me
and said hey
maybe you should translate these things
and um i
i was like yeah okay and then i started
following up biblio
bibliographical references and before
long i figured out that there were like
over 50 different interlocutors in this
debate
and there were probably you know i mean
as we're going to go on there's a number
of different positions on what christian
philosophy consists in
some of which are compatible with each
other and they can be you know brought
together in some sort of
synthesis including blondel's position
with jillson maritime's position uh
augmented by sertian and marcel and
atm born and all these other great
thinkers
what it did show me is that everybody
who like comes out of the gates and says
oh this is an easy problem
christianity is this and philosophy is
this or theology's this and philosophy
is this
full of [ __ ] i remember actually
when i was uh in the um erasmus
institute seminar
with uh aleister mcintyre right at which
i presented some of this stuff
um by the way mcintyre actually had
translated
brahir and gave me a copy of his
translation that i could compare my
translation against
he'd done it for some of his students
and he said don't publish this but you
can take a look at it
there was a guy who is he was actually
an economics professor and he was from
like an evangelical background
and we're in the bathroom you know and
he says oh so what's your project and i
said well i'm working on the
you know the issue of christian
philosophy and he was like oh that's an
easy one
you know chris you know uh philosophy is
this and christianity is this so
christian philosophy is blah blah blah
and like immediately i was like this guy
doesn't know what the hell he's talking
about in part because he's never like
like thought through these complex
issues that the the thinkers translated
here
are working through or you know jose is
doing in his spirit of medieval
philosophy or
some of the other thinkers are doing as
well
b were any of the players involved in
the resistance i
i don't know i mean there's there's a
ton of players so you'd want to look up
their names and then see whether they're
involved in the resistance
mark looking for a tip on an unrelated
issue
did any of these thinkers engage in any
noteworthy discussion of the nature and
role of liturgy
good question um
yeah but i don't know that stuff
um i mean blondel talks about some of
that stuff
i think that um jill soul may have
weighed in
but as a philosopher you know in in some
of his things
um some of the other people who are
more minor players in the debates may
have done so but that's that's not an
area of my
my you know like study or specialization
um infinite loop loved watching your
series where do you think the different
perspectives of philosophy come from
does the culture of the country mold
certain philosophers
yeah probably to some degree but
philosophy is also like breaking free of
your social
situation and engaging it you know using
the
range of human rationality to think
things out oftentimes in
in you know discussion with other
philosophers
where do i think the different
perspectives of philosophy come from
i mean lots and lots of different
factors i would guess
some of which may be i think william
james is probably right about this some
of which may be
temperamental and a lot of which
probably have to do with not the culture
of the country but the culture of the
academic
setting that one is in which could be
dictated by the country but could also
be i mean think about like
the french secular super secular third
republic
which didn't give blondel a job when he
graduated
uh in 1893 after
you know publishing action which was his
dissert
his second dissertation he wrote two
dissertations one in latin and one in
french
and he was um first they couldn't they
wouldn't find a job for him and then
second they put him way the hell out in
the sticks
you know like the worst job postings
that he could get because he was a
catholic
um you know blondel came up through that
system and he's like i'm gonna
i'm gonna work this system from the
inside
um so very often social factors
they could go one way they could go
another way you know
all right um well we're at one o'clock
so
i am going to um call it a
a session call it a day i have to get to
some other work i have a conference i
have to get ready for uh
on monday where where
me and harold covley are on deck first
for the aristotle and aristotelian
conference
and i've also got a class opening monday
as well
so um
well i'll take timothy's thing i've
often wondered how much the first world
war transformed much of the continent
sense of the problem of evil theodicy
role of philosophy
how this might have surfaced in the
debates played no role in the debates at
all
so i guess not not too much
i mean they're not really talking that
much about
the problem of evil and theodicy in
these debates they're really much more
talking about the nature
scope objects discipline of philosophy
all right so i'm gonna i'm going to
schedule another one of these where
we'll go
into the next part we're almost through
the very first part of the introduction
and then pretty soon we're going to
start talking about what do these guys
actually think
about christian philosophy so thanks
everybody for joining in
and i will see you next time